you didn't turn up for the Owen Paterson
votes at all that's right isn't it
I I can't recall you didn't turn up for
the Boris Johnson
um vote at all did you no I was a a
charity dinner for Jewish but yesterday
you were bind on the rules of cricket uh
take us through that I I chose to
fulfill my obligation to an incredible
charity so the Privileges committee has
accused seven MPS of trying to undermine
and impune its work the leader of the
house has condemned this do you think
that they should apologize to the house
I haven't actually gone through the
report yet so
you haven't read the report uh no I
haven't been through the report yet in
detail I've seen it being reported and
I've been very clear in the past that
you asked that Goldsmith to apologize
yes because so you have read it
sufficiently to note that Zach Goldsmith
should apologize yes I've read the
findings report I haven't read the
report from cover to cover no but I have
three pages long